the nation of The Gambia sits here on
the west coast of Africa entirely
surrounded by Senegal as the name
suggests the country's borders follow
the river Gambia and not much else and
in spite of it being a European Colonial
invention its people having a lot in
common with the Senegalese and both
Nations leaders at one point actively
wanting to unite The Gambia are still an
independent nation which raises the
question why why does The Gambia exist
as an independent state to begin what's
Now The Gambia was in the 15th century a
part of the Mali Empire like many other
African States at this time Mali was
visited by Europeans in this case it was
the Portuguese who quickly became an
important trade partner however Portugal
was soon troubled with the spot of
non-existence when it was conquered by
Spain the Portuguese royal family in
Exile quickly sold the rights to trade
with Gambia to England which promptly
began exploring the area and they built
some forts along the mouth of the river
but the English presence there was
minimal into the 18th century at this
point England was now a part of the
United Kingdom and the UK had a
long-standing rivalry with France which
was also so trying to monopolize trade
in the region when the Seven Years War
started the British seized all of French
Senegal this was reversed after
Britain's defeat during the American
Revolutionary War and Britain only
retained the lands either side of the
river and after the Napoleonic wars were
done Britain was slightly confused about
what to do with the region it had
primarily been used for the export of
slaves to the new world but since that
was on the decline it seemed that the
only reason for keeping the Gambia would
be to annoy France as such new plan get
rid of it in the late 19th century
Britain and France discussed what Gambia
would be swapped for in return for
Britain abandoning The Gambia France
would renounce its claim to the north of
Sierra Leone this never happened though
because France soon found itself at war
with Prussia this mattered because one
the French were kind of busy and so
didn't have much time to negotiate the
transfer of these lands and two giving
France a valuable Port whilst it was at
war with Prussia would be seen by those
in Berlin as Britain giving its support
to France as such No Deal after France's
defeat in its changing government
another proposal was put forward The
Gambia would merge with Senegal in
return for France giving up the every
Coast this was a much better deal for
Britain and so obviously the government
was for the trade the problem was that
France was still seen as a potential
enemy and importantly many feared that
setting the precedent of just giving
away a colony would mean that no one
would want to invest in them as such The
Gambia remained under British control
until its independence in 1965 half a
decade after Senegal the new governments
of these nations thought to build close
ties and in the early 1980s both formed
the senegambian Confederation the
problem was that while Senegal saw it as
a bridge to unification the gambian saw
it as an easy way of not having to pay
for their own defense both sides
discussed further integration but the
gambian government didn't want to lose
their own power or give up their
economic policy and in 1989 Senegal
withdrew from the Confederation and
thereafter The Gambia remains an
independent nation I hope you enjoyed
this episode with a special thanks to my
patrons James bisonnet Kelly moneymaker
Sky Chappelle katowitzka Andy McGehee
Alex Schwinn AF Firefly Marcus arsner
Spencer Lightfoot wire hockey Marvin
cassow Captain psydog boogly
wigglycamoon Yoon Winston caywood Gustav
swan Khalid Alderwood Maggie Paskowski
the macquapa Anthony Beckett calling Dr
Howard Dr Fine Dr Howard Coppertone
shewenin spinning three plates words
about books podcast rod D Martin Jim
stronberg Miss is it and Charles the
first